[Music]
hello YouTube chess Louis in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the
eighth episode of dirty chess tricks
again Sicilian in this episode I'm going
to show you some wonderful tricky lines
in the names of which Rosalie may attack
from the white perspective the opening
arises after the following order Evo c5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and now Bishop
to b5 when I check this position in
online database I found out that the
highest played move in this position is
g6 and this is exactly we are going to
concentrate in this video after the move
g6 my recommendation is why should
continue with the Moose III and the most
popular choice by the black over here is
Bishop to g7 however if your opponent
plays Knight to f6 then I have attached
a simple line which is available in the
BGN so kindly go through it Bishop to g7
and now the obvious move d4 grabbing the
space in the center the mainline runs
with the move c-captain c4c captures d4
so at first sight it looks like what has
this very impressive center but after
blacks next reply which is very obvious
Queen to b6 and it looks like white is
in trouble because normally these three
pieces are attacking on d4 but white has
a loose bishop on the B file so is it
white in the trouble well of course not
and in fact white has deliberately
played this opening to invite black in
his tricky camp the tricky business
start with the move Knight to c3 so cam
beating the central pawn now as I have
highlighted over here the most popular
choice by the black is to play Knight
caps is d4 however I have also included
other black options so let's see each my
turn
the first more I want to consider this
night captures default which is obvious
choice by the black well here white has
this very cunning reply Knight to d5
so not only attacking the Queen but I at
the c7 square and black Queen cannot
take this bishop because of the night
check on the c7 here the force replies
Knight captures f3 apart from it in one
blitz game my opponent tried the move
Queen to e5 which at first sight looks
very natural but after some forcing
reply by white let's say Bishop to d2
Queen to d8 Knight captaincy for Bishop
captures d4 rope to Sivan I at the c7
square so my opponent has to forcefully
play the move Bishop to b6 but after
Bishop to e3 trying to destroy the
defender Bishop check and b4 I think
white is coming out with a winning
position the game continued with the
movie six but after Queen to d4
attacking the rook f6 and now pawn
captures pawn captures and castle in the
King side black all pcs are doing photo
shoot at the back rank and no wonder
white is going to crush black in the
middle game so accordingly the force
supply over here is a knight captures f3
check and after Queen captures f3 if now
Queen - if I check then Bishop to d2 is
a very strong reply so again black
responses force black has the only move
Queen to d6 Queen d8 is a big time
blunder which happens in one game where
white quickly get a winning gauge after
Bishop to F for targeting weak c7 square
so only way to defend this is to play
ePHI but after White's next crushing
reply Queen to c3 black has already lost
the opening battle
okay so Queen to d6 what else
and after that my recommendation is you
continue with the castle on the Kings
side and Kylie note black doesn't have
time to play the movie six because then
Bishop to f4 is a very strong reply by
white so again
black has to stop Bishop f4 and the only
good way to stop it is to play Bishop to
e5 I read this position against a feeder
master in online feed HS arena and I
think this is one of the model game
which highlight what kind of danger
Black has fallen into him here I
continue with the move rook to d1 so
trying to get a discovered attack on the
Queen and if my opponent has played
Bishop to s2 then King to h1 is a very
strong reply as black is strictly
falling behind in development so in the
game
my opponent decided to play Queen to be
aged getting out of the discovery I
continue with the move Queen to d3 so
now indeed there is an x-ray going on on
d7 and believe it or not this position
is very hard to play as a black moves
such as a6 can be met with the move f4
so in the game my opponent played the
best reply that is bishop check and
after king - h1 he responded with the
move Bishop to b6 now if you carefully
look at this position black is a clear
to pawn up but amazingly enough this is
a lost position for black as white
leading development will literally kill
the black I continue with the move
Bishop to e3 and now but has a very
simple plan to execute that is rook to
c1 and deliver Knight to c7 and this
plant is not easy to stop for example if
black continued initially with Knight to
f6 then white can simply take this night
and become a piece up if he played moves
such as a 6 then if I can simply ignore
this and continue with the move rook to
c1 as after pawn captures and the Moon
Knight to b6 black is in completely
hopeless position this attack is so
potent that
engine is suggesting Knight to f6 and
completely give up the Queen so
considering all this in the game
my opponent try the move b6 but I'm
afraid this is not going to help blacks
position as after the move rook to Sivan
black doesn't have time to play Bishop
to b7 position is so worse that he has
to continue with the MU King to her fate
but even after this move white attack
rolled on the board with the mu f4 so
now ePHI is on the card so my opponent
stop it with the MU abscess
if I comes anyways after pawn captures
pawn captures and Bishop captures why it
has this wonderful move Bishop to d4 so
once again pinning this bishop thus
renewing the threat of Knight to c7 and
it's important to note here that moves
such as d6 is not possible at all
because White has this dazzling shot
Knight captures c7 hahaha no matter
however black captures let's say Knight
captures a 7 then white can continue
with the move Bishop captures and after
pawn captures and Queen check black king
will hardly survive from this position
so see black has such a tough time
against this opening in the game after a
long thought my opponent continued with
the move Queen to d6 which I think the
only saving resource but here white
continued with the move rook to even a
tactical move so in case of Queen
captures defy White has a strong reply
of rook captures ePHI and black cannot
even play Bishop captures d4
because after that white can continue
with the Queen captures attacking the
rook and the obvious move Knight to f6
can be dealt with the stunning flow rook
captures c7 and black cannot even touch
this 9 because if he foolishly capture
this Knight then Queen to g7 is a
checkmate
so again black is forced to play the
only reply that is Bishop to f6 and what
funny thing I found about this game is
Black has played a plenty of moves from
built this dark square Bishop and Queen
and risked all of his species are
slipping at the back rank okay before I
move on I like you to pause this video
and find out a continuation where white
is completely winning okay I hope you
find this wonderful reply that is Knight
captures f6 Knight kept his f6 and now
the deciding blow yup Bishop captures f6
black cannot take this bishop either way
so in the game he tried the MU Queen
kept his d3 but then comes bishop Jack
King to f7 and now simple Bishop
captures b3 and white emerged with extra
piece so I think this model game has
given you the great inside how white
should continue against various options
when black responds with the Moon Knight
captures d4 now the second obvious move
I want to consider over here is Bishop
captures d4 well this is not a good move
the simple reason is white can
immediately take this bishop and by this
exchange black has severely weakened the
dark square around this game here if
black continued with the move Knight
captures d 4 then Bishop to e3 is a very
strong reply so only good move over here
is Queen captures d4 afterwards but
should avoid this Queen exchange and
continue with the move Queen to me -
okay mainline continue with the move
Knight to f6 and now why should
highlight the problem in the black camp
by throwing up that dark square bishop
with the move Bishop 26 so in near
distance future black cannot even castle
and this gives all the time in the world
to build up an attack I like to show you
one of my blitz game against a 2000
a player where my opponent continued
with the move Asics attacking the bishop
first I get the tempo with the move rook
to d1 attacking his Queen he responded
with the Moon Queen to e5 and now I
simply responded with the move Bishop to
c4 if Knight to d4 then Queen to d2 is a
very strong reply so in the game
my opponent played the move d6 so maybe
his idea is to take this light square
Bishop out and then castle on the Queen
side but I'm afraid this plant is too
slow and this is never going to happen
because of white next forcing
continuation before I move on I like you
to pause this video and find out what is
the continuation here which stop black
castle on the Queen side did you find it
let's see the sequence start with the
move Bishop to g7 attacking the rook
rook to g8 now Bishop captures f6 and
black is forced to capture with the pawn
because if Queen to f6 then Knight to d5
and White will get at least exchange in
this line so ef6 is force and after that
why should continue with the move Knight
to d5 so again looking at the c7 square
King to d8 allows white to launch all
the devastation after Castle so in the
game my opponent played the safest
option that is king to f8 but then the
game continued with the move fo hitting
the Queen Queen to h5 again we should
not extend the Queen because we are on
the attacking position so I continue
with the move Queen to e3 and after
Bishop to g4 I calmly played rope to d2
now indeed white is threatening the move
Knight to f6
so my opponent defended with the mu King
to g7 but it turns out that this is a
big-time disaster as after white's next
strong reply Queen to c3
Paul is a simply commoner he tried
counter-attacking move but after Queen
check King to g8 and simply castle on
the kingside black is completely busted
rook to e4 happened but then Quinn kept
his d6 so black doesn't have any time to
capture the bishop because he has to
address the issue of Knight to f6
so he tried to move rook to e6 but this
allows a favorable exchange that is
Queen captures c6 Bishop captures Knight
check regaining the Queen with a
superior position because after King to
air Jade Knight captures Queen still
Black is attacking to sports but this is
not a big deal as White has this move in
the picture look to c1 attacking the
bishop and after Bishop captures e - and
the move Knight to f6
white emerged with an extra exchange the
third move I want to consider is e 6
well a black is not going to grab this
fall then of course white is going to
consolidate his center with the move
Bishop to e3 and now two moves has been
tried from this position amongst them
the only accurate reply is Knight G to
e7 against this my recommendation is you
continue with the MU castle on the King
side and after the move D Phi Y should
continue with the move Bishop captures
Knight pawn captures Knight to e4
attacking the Queen Queen to c7 and now
if I wear white has a clear cut sitting
target on the c6 where on the counter
part black doesn't have any concrete
plan to play if black is not familiar in
this position that he can obviously
plate this blunder new a6 which happens
in the few games where white has stamped
his advantage immediately with the moved
e-file
attacking the Queen Queen to a5
and now Bishop to e2 so black has it
hanging night one of the top game
continued from here he kept his defy II
captures Nephi and now black blade
Knight to e5 okay White Castle on the
kingside and black exchange one pair of
night after night captures and Bishop
captures well at first sight this
position look innocent but White has a
decisive advantage because black king is
Scott in the center if d6 then Bishop to
f4 is a very strong reply so black
blocked the file with the Moon Knight to
e7 but then white continue with the move
Bishop to g5 so stopping black to castle
on the Kings side maybe black thought
that after the mu f 6 he has a very
acceptable position but I'm afraid after
White's next reply d6 black has wake up
from his dreamland if FG fire then rook
to even is a very strong reply so in the
game black continued with the move
Knight to f5 but after rook check black
has to forcefully play the move King to
her fate after this the game finished
very quickly white continue with the
move Bishop to d2 trying to get a
discovery on the Queen black responds
with the move Queen to b6 attacking b2
and now white played a strong reply
Knight to d5 Queen obviously cannot take
this d6 pawn because of the move Bishop
to b4 trapping the baby so in the game
black decided to play Queen captures b2
but after Bishop to c3 Queen to a3 and
the move Queen to e2 black is completely
busted
he tried King to f7 but after night to
c7 attacking the rook rook to b8 and now
why deliver this easy checkmate Bishop
to c4 King to her fate and now Queen to
even is a checkmate so that was a 23
moves men
by the white which highlight ye6 is not
a good choice for the black last but not
least what happens if you open in place
a six which recently comes into the
picture
well I think it's not a big deal because
why should continue with the move Bishop
to e2 and now if allowed then as usual
what is going to consolidate his Center
with the move Bishop to e3
so if black is hoping for any advantage
then he has to grab this pawn and the
best way to grab is to play Knight
captricity for when after that this is
upgrade version of the line which we
have seen earlier because here white
will continue with the move Knight to d5
attacking the Queen Knight to f3 check
bishop we have three Queen to d6 and
this time around
White has this superior move Bishop to
f4 and no matter however black plays he
get lost position in the opening if
Aoife then Bishop to g5 is a very strong
reply so in one on line bets game my
1900 rate Aida Poland continue with the
move Bishop to e5 but after an accurate
sequence might obtain a winning position
before I show it to you I want to
calculate my own how I should continue
from here onwards okay I hope you find
this easy sequence that is Bishop
captures Queen captures rope to sivan
king to a fade and now the star mu
castle on the Kings side and no matter
whatever black plays black is going to
lose a piece for example Knight to f6
which happens in the game but after the
Moon Knight to b6 black has immediately
hit the resign button I hope you enjoy
and long this wonderful tricky line
against g6 variation in Jerusalem oh
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe
and comment on my video and I'll meet
you in my next episode very soon bye
I'll take care